Jason is in Miami
hi Jason welcome to the Dave Ramsey show
Hey
better than I deserve what's up awesome
I have a quick question whether I should
rent or buy according to my current
financial situation so on 25 years old
and have about eighty-five thousand
dollars in cash in the bank and I do
live at home still but I definitely want
to decide whether to rent or buy in the
next six months good out of my friend's
house okay so I was wondering what you
would do in my situation very good what
are you do for a living I own a
photography business and an online
e-commerce store and then I also have
some income property two income
properties in Georgia
excellent next one are they both paid
for yep both paid for and they produce
about five about 550 in cash each so
it's about a thousand dollars a month I
received excellent so what is your
income these days it's about ninety
thousand why'd it go oh when you're 25
years old you got 80 grand in the bank
yep ding ding well done well done
are you seeing a young lady at this time
no I'm single which is it'll be one
income essentially hmm so I guess I'm
worried about whether I should buy
something or rent and then figure out
later on in life whether I should buy
I just think renting is essentially
throwing away money especially in Miami
where it's so high to rent but it's also
expensive to buy to solve divine an
older smaller apartment which would be
20% down and homeowners association
every month mm-hmm so I can't really
afford a home per se mm-hmm well you can
you should think about how you did it
but it's you're pretty industrious young
guy you got a lot of stuff going on very
well done very well done well I mean I'm
with you you move out it within six
months and get yourself established and
in terms of paying your own bills and
those kinds of things and it's okay if
you rent I don't want you're renting as
a way of life but there's people get in
such a hurry to buy
we're renting sometimes it's just
patience and so if you rented for six
months and during that time you piled up
some more money and you had a real
strong downpayment he caused you to buy
a different property there was a better
property well that would have been a
good thing but I don't want you running
for six years and like what I what I
thought about is if I do buy a small
apartment something in a small apartment
essentially if I do I'll grow it in
three or four years and I just rent that
out and then that covers my mortgage and
then I decide what to do later yeah you
could you could get it paid off and then
keep it like you've got those other
properties that are paid off and they're
money-making machines when they're paid
off maybe so and then you know it's okay
because here's the thing if as long as
you don't buy something that can never
be sold because it sucks so bad you know
it just it doesn't matter you sell it if
you don't like it in two years right so
my son Daniel bought a home and a year
and a half later met the young lady of
his dreams and six months or eight
months later they were married and we
were actually talking about this weekend
and she likes the house that he bought
just fine but it's always going to be
his house that he bought and so at some
point they will change houses just
because the old joke is is that you
didn't know you bought the wrong house
until you marry the girl and she tells
you right that's the old joke now that
Alison wasn't doing that to Daniel but
but you and your girl you know your
girlfriend of the future might not do
that to you but no matter what you buy
you're gonna change a phase of life when
you do get married and have kids and
you're probably gonna move again so it's
okay it's okay
it's an if you buy you a nice little
condo there get you something going in
the Miami area and it's not as long as
it's something that's that can be resold
that you don't get yourself stuck in
something then just sell it when your
life changes a little bit but it's okay
it's okay we're out for six months and
even before you do that but I again just
number one real estates not permanent
you don't have to keep it forever
there's no rule that says you have to
stay there forever especially if you buy
care
and watch what you're doing and you've
been wise so far number two if you're
single and you buy a house know that
there's a probability that you're
probably going to sell that house when
you do get married later especially if
you're in your twenties that that's just
a high probability that's okay there's
nothing wrong with that just kind of
have that in the back of your head and
that way you won't be upset later when
that comes down the road